what I've done here is I've copied and
pasted a bunch of pictures that signify
events in our history when you think
about history on a grander scale that
most of us have some relation to or we
kind of have heard it talked about a
little bit and the whole point of this
is to try to understand or try to begin
to understand how long 13.7 billion
years is so just to start off I have
here this is the best depiction I could
find where I didn't have copyrights is
from NASA of the Big Bang and I've
talked about it several times the Big
Bang occurred 13.7 billion years ago and
then if we go a little bit forward
actually a lot forward we get to the
formation of our actual solar system and
the earth this is kind of a
protoplanetary disk or a depiction of a
protoplanetary disk forming around our
young Sun and so this right here is 4.5
billion years ago now this over here
once again these aren't pictures of them
these are just depictions because no one
was there with a camera this is what we
think the asteroid that killed the
dinosaurs look like when it was
impacting earth and it killed the
dinosaurs 65 million years ago 65
million 65 million years ago years ago
so until then we had land dinosaurs and
then this as far as the current theories
go got rid of them now we'll fast
forward a little bit more at about 3
million years ago
3 million let me do this in a color that
you can see about 3 million so 3 million
years ago years ago our ancestors look
like this this is Australopithecus
afarensis this she's this is I think a
depiction this is Lucy this is one of
our probably many of us share I believe
the the theory is that all of us have
some of some DNA from her but this was
three million years ago and you fast
forward some more and you actually have
the first modern humans appearing on the
planet people that looked and thought
like you and me this is two hundred two
hundred thousand years ago
that's right over here obviously this
drawing was done much later but this is
a depiction of a modern human so 200,000
years ago and then you fast forward even
more and I don't want to keep picking on
Jesus I did that when him getting on the
jetliner and I don't mean any offense to
anyone I just keep picking Jesus because
frankly our calendars is kind of he's a
good person that most people most people
know about 2,000 years ago and so when
we associate you know kind of a lot of
modern history occurring after his birth
so I'll put this right here is obviously
a painting of the birth of Jesus and
this is 2,000 years ago
2,000 years and then this might be a
little bit a little bit American centric
but you know the Declaration of
Independence it was a major event
actually even on a worldwide basis it
was the first secular democracy that
based on a kind of constitutional
democracy that showed up on the planet
they had gotten rid of they said we
don't want the King of England anymore
and this was about 234 years ago 234 and
I always remembered because I was born
almost on the 200th anniversary so you
just have to add my age to 200 so this
is 234 years ago so these are all these
are all events or periods of time that
that we've heard about and we've talked
about it and people throw around these
type of years but what I want to do in
this video is relate it to timescales
that we can comprehend so instead of the
Big Bang occurring 13.7 billion years
ago let's pretend like it occurred ten
years ago because we can most of us
especially if you're over the age of 10
can kind of understand what ten years is
it's a very very long period of time but
something that's well within our
lifetimes well within our experience so
let's say let's say the 13.7 billion
instead of saying the Big Bang occurred
13.7 billion years ago
let's pretend like it occurred ten years
ago ten years ago and if we pretend that
it occurred ten years ago let's think
about how many years or minutes or hours
ago each of these events would have
occurred so if the Big Bang which is
really 13.7 billion years if it really
had occurred ten
years ago and we scaled everything down
if we had scaled everything down then
the earth the earth would have been
created about 3.3 years ago so this
would have been three point three years
ago so still nothing you know nothing
kind of amazing about this this is a
significant fraction of the age of the
universe so not that not that
mind-blowing just yet
but if we go all the way to when the
dinosaurs were extinct the last land
dinosaurs
now the 65 million years and this will
give you an appreciation of the
difference between million and billion
if the universe was only ten years old
this then the dinosaurs would have been
extinct seventeen days ago not even a
month ago the dinosaurs would have been
extinct so the if the universe was
created when I was you know I'll you
know just graduated well I'm in my 30s
now so when I was 24 just last month the
dinosaurs would have gone extinct and he
gets even crazier 17 days ago the
dinosaurs would have extinct
Australopithecus afarensis would have
walked on the earth 19 hours ago
yesterday 19 hours ago 19 hours ago she
would have been walking around on the
planet and modern humans modern humans
wouldn't have shown up until 80 minutes
ago 80 80 minutes a little over hour
there wasn't even a modern human then
did you know the universe was ten years
it didn't take until just very recently
the last hour for us to see someone that
looks something like us looks and thinks
something like us fast forward even more
the birth of Jesus if the universe was
ten years old instead of 13.7 and
billion and we scaled everything down
then the birth of Jesus would have been
46 seconds ago 46 seconds ago and then
if we fast forward all the way to the
Declaration of Independence this would
have occurred this would occurred five
seconds ago five seconds ago so this
isn't quite quite as mind as
mind-blowing as the scale of the
universe but in my mind this is pretty
still pretty amazing I mean all that's
happened
1776 on a global basis could have been
encapsulated in five seconds if the
universe was if the age of the universe
was ten years so hopefully that gives
you a little bit of a perspective in the
next video I'm going to compare instead
of instead of condensing things in time
I'm going to compare the scale to kind
of a distance scale so we can kind of
say hey if the age if the universe was
the number of pixels on my screen how
big would each of these things be